hello everybody
i'm going to slowly start hoping that
everybody who wanted to join joined or
joined brief
soon my name is gosha conversa i work as
a current developer for full from
research and i'm going to be talking
about special statistics
um looking from the data side mostly but
also
i'll touch a bit talk a bit about the
models
and when we talk about the special point
data
here we are concerned about point
patterns so
um say events in space so this is like
the three cinephores called deposits and
this is the situation
when where interpolation between points
doesn't make sense so this is
this is not or maybe some people are
familiar cricking we are in a
point pattern situation
okay so to start with we introduced a
new data container which is called
spatial point data
and this is a container for points
locations and observation region
and there are three main ways to obtain
special point data we can create it
directly from points or from points in
region or
from points with annotations
and that can have a region
or no note region we can generate
special point data
from a point process and we can also
obtain special point data from accurate
collection
of resource objects
so first i want to show how to create a
special poindender from
your own data let's say so say that we
fetch some data
and some large cities in canada and you
see they come to us as entities
and we can input them as locations
directly
into the special point data and we can
provide the region which is also an
entity
and then we have a special point data so
we call the lighted form which
tells us here in this um
here the the tape data type is
geographical we have 96
points the physical dimension is still
and if you expand it you get a little
more information
about the region we can then just plot
the points using the geolist plot
and we can extract more information from
the special point data via properties
the quick information about the data
it's under a summary which kind of gives
us the
similar information that delighted form
but also tells us about the notations
and we see that there are no annotations
and we can extract observation region
and look at the points and this is a
geographical data so the points are
stored in a compact way in a single geo
position
so um as i mentioned there are no
annotations so we got
at empty association here but we can add
information about the points
so say that i'm gonna extract the names
for all the cities and then i'm
gonna create a new object that has the
locations but also
has the information about the names for
each city so that's our annotation
and the way that it's here it's given
with a key which is the
name of the keys the names and we give
the same
region so now when we look at the
summary it will have
the line here about the annotations and
it will give us the keys
for the annotations and then we can use
this annotations in a visualization for
example create a tooltip
and then plot everything using
geographics where we can show the whole
region
the locations and when you move around
uh you can
just basically see the names of all the
uh
locations okay a side note um i
mentioned that we can put in observation
region
um and so it's important to know that
not every region can be a valid
observation region
it has to be parameter free free full
dimensional and bounded
and we introduce the function that tests
these conditions this is spatial
observation
region q and so when we look at uh the
region that i used before
uh the the entity uh of country canada
and we can test it that it's true
because this entity has a polygon
uh property and if the region is not
provided then
it's going to be inferred from the
points using the rip eurozone estimator
which you can
think as a dilated convex hole
and so um but here we i create a special
point data just with the cds and i can
extract observation region
which is a polygon based on the geo
positions
and you can visualize this region with
the points
and so now you see that this region is a
polygon in space
and it's not the whole canada country as
we had before
and the um the way to obtain the the
ripley resonant region
is also a function um in involved from
language now so you can
generate some random points say on a
disk and create the
repliers on region on the points and
then when we uh visualize this
we see that the blue is the original
region from which we generated the
points
we see the points and we see the orange
the replay region
um the idea about with the with the
repliers on region is that no um no
points will be close to the boundary
so the dilation happens to kind of
create the region which will not have
the observation points close to the
boundary and when you look at the
original region and the points you see
that some points are almost sitting on
the boundary
just like here
okay so we can obtain switch up upon
data simulating
um a point process and the function to
simulate
from point processes is called a random
point configuration
and the process from which i'm i will
simulate here it's in homogeneous
poisson point process where we can
specify the density as
a function of location and we provide
the dimension
and i will not talk much about the the
models the point processes
that's going to be covered more in
eduardo stock at 11 30. so right after
this one
so let's define the process and let's
sample from the process
over the disk so you see that the random
point configuration takes the process
and takes the the region and now we see
that the data type is cartesian we have
uh 2618 points and the physical
dimension is two
and then we can visualize the the the
plots with the
region okay and then
we can also get the special point data
from uh
you know set of curated spatial point
data sets
that will be available as a resource
objects and
for now uh what i do is i load this
locally from my
uh computer here but that will be make
public at some point
um and so here i have a resource object
and to extract
the data the spatial point data we have
to use the resource data that's
gets us the main data which is the the
form in the form of
spatial point data and um
when we started the data you know
summary is a good place to start
besides you know plotting so i can plot
and look at the summary and it tells me
that i have a notation here
so um i want to see what's the
annotation and it gives me that
um the set of um
you know names for the species so i can
see that i have two types of species
um we have a way to create a subset from
the original data which is
called spatial point select so in a
spatial point select i give the original
data and then i would like to select all
the
points or the locations that the species
is the cataglyphus
so that gives me another special pun
data and i do the same for the second
type of species and you know your sanity
check is that you
only keep the the right species
so the annotations on my subset only
have one type of species
and then we can plot them both color
differently and and see
how how they intermingle or whether
they're not intermingle
okay in study of data we
we also want to understand you know how
the
point density function varies
you know per length or per array or per
volume depending on which dimension
we're working
and so point density it's generally a
function that describes this
variation and um this is not maybe a
density in a strict
sense because when we integrate this
function over the observation region
we're gonna get the total number of
points within this observation
region and involve information though
from language we have three functions
that are dedicated to compute point
density
they all use different distinct
approaches so we have point density
histogram
point density and smooth point density
and i will talk about
each in a bit more detail point density
is an adaptive density estimator it's
one point per bean so let's recall our
ant data
and we can compute the point density
using voronoid oscillations
and we can show the density
um with the data points so you see one
one point per bean and um the
the closer the points are to each other
the smaller the beans get
and so we have a higher value of density
what you see also here is that point
density
returns point the density function and
this gonna be the
the output for all the density functions
and point density function
is a function of a location so we can
plot it
as uh you know using plot 3d can plot
the surface
for the points the locations inside the
observation region
histogram point density is a partition
based estimator
and the beam specification will control
the smoothing
so um automatically this is this is what
the what we get when we um on the
compute histogram point density on data
it's a binning which is aggregated mesh
uh method and to show it better with the
points
we see that the beans are have their own
color
and we can specify the the shape of the
beans so maybe i want to have a hexagon
and it and also we can you know specify
the
the size which can be controlled for
example by the
uh number of beans that we want and so
this is the plot for a different bean
count so you see
uh the more beans we have you know the
more varied the
density function is uh less beans gives
us a more smooth
result um now smooth point density
is a kernel based estimator which is um
controlled by the bandwidth and the
kernel functions and this
is extension of the kernel mixture
distribution and smooth kernel
distribution two regions so um
we're gonna obtain the point density
functions in the properties
of of this type point density functions
we see distribution
and this distribution you know
corresponds to either kernel mixture of
smooth
kernel distribution and uh the choice of
which can be controlled via options
in smooth point density and so we can
for example
plot pdf of this distribution because
this is well defined
distribution involved from language
okay the next question that we ask in
studying uh
point data is whether the the points in
the collection
are uniformly distributed and
independently
and independently from each other so
whether they are having a
uh interactions like ripple repelling
each other or
uh attracting each other so if a data um
if the data is independently and
uniformly distributed the points then we
call that it
call it exhibiting a complete spatial
randomness
and it also means that the point density
is constant across the observation
region
and the numbers of points in any
subregion are
an independent and identically
distributed random variables
and the model for this is a is a poisson
point process
where the first parameter here is
exactly this constant point density
and the second parameter is the
dimension in in the space
so when you sample from this
point process you can look at the points
and you kind of see well i don't know if
this is a uniform or not
and so we know that the
point density should be constant so we
can visualize the point density of the
sample and see if this
is constant and i still cannot really
tell because the you know the density
visualization does not give us a
computable answer
and therefore we need a test we need to
be able to
have a hypothesis test and we introduce
spatial randomness tests
which works as any other test involved
from language so
by default if you just input the the
sample it returns the p value
but we can also ask for the test
conclusion
and here we see that that this this this
this is not um passing the test actually
this data even though it was generated
for the poison point process
and also notice that it's based on a
specific um test
in this case chi square test and so
spatial randomness test is really a
super
test and we have more tests available in
size
and you can use another test for example
and here the p-value it's on the border
line so
it really varies
as always okay and
um that was kind of a i'm going to show
you that it's difficult to tell whether
the data it's it's
truly um you know uh random spatially
random
and this is another example that that
shows why things are kind of difficult
to
to tell and so um i have an example here
for clustered data and i will simulate
two cluster processes over a
geographical region and they will differ
only in the average number of points per
cluster
the first uh parameter here is the
intensity of points in the
parent process so the cluster centers
and cluster radius tells you the size of
the cluster so the first
first process and the second process is
called modern point process and i just
simulate
both processes
and this might take a little bit but
don't be discouraged
um
okay so we have two samples so then we
can just plot them next to each other
okay and so they look um they look
different because the the second sample
has more points
and now we can test you know um the
special randomness
and so here we have that they're not
rejected and the funny thing is that i
was doing this
you know on with a different seed you
know one was rejected one was not
rejected
but basically the point is that in this
situation um the test does not rejected
the null hypothesis so
even though both um our both samples are
created using the cluster model
um the test tells us that they will they
they will may come
from a uniform uh you know uniform
uh process so they may be uniformly
distributed
so this is not um easy in a way this is
not
evident to identify your you know the
model from which your data comes
okay and to further study this
this question you know of of a complete
spatial randomness
we have the second order measures which
are called homogeneity measures
and they um they also
study how you know how the points how
uniform the points are distributed
in the observation uh window and so the
there are the functions here and i
grouped them
because they have a connections so it's
replica investage l
by cigal is basically a function of
reprique
empty space f nearest neighbor g spatial
j
where spatial j is a function of the
first two and we have a pre-correlation
g
so when we look at the replica at some
distance
r and multiply this by the mean point
intensity it gives us the expected
number of points within the distance r
and as i said basadel is just a function
over the pre-k
and usually these two statistics are
used to compare the data with the
with the ideal model of the poisson
point process
for which the replica is just some
polynomial
of order of the dimension and beside l
it's gonna be always linear in
r so um again i'm gonna take the cluster
uh process and then just compare
uh the replica of this cluster sample
with
the ideal um you know replica of the
poisson point process
and one thing to notice here is that we
get the point statistic function
before for the densities we get the
point uh density function here we get a
point statistic function
and so we can plot and compare that the
cluster sample
and the poisson um you know process
and see that they they are different and
um here for the point statistic
functions we have the properties
stored and i want to just mention this
one the boundary correction
this is a method which is used to
account for the points being on the
boundary or very close to it
and we can extract the the boundary
correction that was used
in this case to compute this replica the
board and margin
and this can be changed to different
methods or can be disabled completely
using
option spatial boundary correction
um so empty space f and nearest neighbor
g
are almost the same because they give
probability of finding a point within
distance
r it only different from where and so
either from arbitrary location
as in empty space f or from a typical
point in the collection
and spatial j is the function of the
first two
and so when we when you look at the
poisson point process
both the probability of finding a
a point within distance r from a
location
or from a typical point in the data are
exactly the same
and you know hence the the spatial j for
the
poisson point process is equal one
and so what we can do here is for
example compare the two
for a data this is a forest data which
um
has observation region which is the
rectangle of size one
and this is a region scaled and one
corresponds to
924 feet so you can plot the data
and you would like to know some
information you know about the data
to have some conclusions you know what
happens
so what i do here i plot
newness neighbor g and i scale it to to
you know to defeat so it will you know
it will give you the probability of
finding
a tree within radius r feet from
either another tree or a random location
within the observation region
and um
as you see this point statistics here
right
um it's computed without any radius and
so this is a pre-computed function and
then when i want to plot it here
you know the computation for each radius
has to happen
and hence the it takes a little bit of
time
to get the plot and so what what we see
here is that
probability from a location is um you
know
is lower for for a low you know for a
small registers
so it's more likely to find another tree
from if you are a tree
so that may hint that basically we're
looking at the cluster data
not definitive answer it's it's one of
the one of the hints that we get
studying data
and pre-correlation g also called uh
radial distribution function this is
uh proportional to the probability
density of finding two points
at the given distance apart and that
could be understood as a derivative of
nearest neighbor g
which was you know having a point you
know finding
finding the probability of um
nearest neighbor g was giving you
probability of finding a nearest
neighbor or
you know a point within a given distance
from established point in the data
and uh despite the name per correlation
g
is not a correlation in the usual sense
with values varying between -1 and 1
and the range is from 0 to infinity and
1
is the value corresponding to complete
spatial randomness
so this is as expected the per
correlation g on the poisson endpoint
process it's always one
it's independent on any um you know
parameter here so
point density dimension no radius and
we can use percolation dtu to see if
there is a
hardcore radius in the in the
percolation collection
so whether the there is some repelling
force
in the data and you can see that
probability of finding two points
which are you know small distance apart
is zero which
would indicate that there is indeed a
hardcore radius and
um that agrees with our model uh which
is exactly
um you know as is called here this is
the
mean point density and this number here
is the hardcore radius
which means we can't find any two points
closer
to each other than this number
okay and then last but not least
um there is another object that we
introduce
that's called spatial bind point data
and it's an object that it's designed to
store aggregated spatial point data
um in a neat and nice way because a lot
of times the point data will
come to us in the aggregated form so i
you know the aggregation happens per zip
area per county
per state and um what i want to
show here is that um the data comes you
know
in you know this kind of way so they say
we have the covet historical test
results from the illinois department of
public health website this is the json
file
and you know like what we're trying to
do is to get the information about the
the latest you know update to get the
total numbers of
you know confirmed cases per county in
illinois
so you can see that we can they uh get
the date of the last
update then if i just ask you know what
is
you know where's my data you know this
looks like that
so okay so i'm getting closer but in a
way this is
all manipulation on you know which parts
i need to take
and so to extract the counties you know
i i need to take this part here
and the next step is to look at this and
see what has to be done
to make sure that we can then match
these counties with the entities
involved from language that will give us
the proper locations that is understood
and the first thing that jumps you know
out
is this that the weed for example has a
space
and involved from language the entities
are written without spaces
the other issue is that we have out of
state
and we also have unassigned so we need
to drop them
so i'm gonna find the positions for this
two problematic you know states that we
need to drop
and then i'm gonna create the beans and
you know
one more thing is that um chicago in the
entity framework is not a county
city so we need to input this as an
entity city
everything else goes to the
administrative division so we create the
bins
we're going to check that we actually
have what we want so we get the entities
now from the um from the values we need
to drop the
the positions that correspond to
unassigned and out of state
sanity check are our lengths the same
okay
between the the values and the beans and
then the nice part is that we create a
special
bin point data bins and
values
and it's running
and i'm just checking if everything is
let's try again
okay while this is running we can look
at the plot
maybe not um i'm just gonna abort that
and show you the plot so basically what
we will get eventually is the ability of
geo religion value plot to support the
elect
directly the spatial um pinpoint data
and i'm just gonna go and uh
re-evaluate stuff and
see that we get everything so elevated
this
and everything looked good
so well bad things happen to good people
for no reason
but anyway um i'll let it run and see
and in the meantime
that's the end of the talk and i thank
you and
i'm gonna see if there are any questions
that i can
answer uh but i'm just gonna keep
looking at this this is warring um
okay
so i'm gonna start from the top
okay
okay i don't see any i see some
uh yes
can you hear me yes what's your question
uh so i was wondering uh it was awesome
talk
uh i was wondering if this these
functions take
uh like a periodicity metric like
such that say if you're running a
molecular dynamics simulation
you typically will use a unit cell where
if you go through the right side of the
unit cell it will come back through the
left such that there's a periodicity
element to it
and distances can be like different
because of that
say if you're near the left side of the
wall on the right side while the
periodic distance is smaller than the
actual distance
please take an argument that accounts
for that um
i don't know um you know we we
we created this in a way that it's uh
somewhat general
you know container and um it can take a
lot of data it can take the structured
data on a regular grid as well
it's just that it's not designed to you
know to
look into the interpolation between the
points so i mean
you know feel free to you know to if you
have the example we can you know meet up
later or
you can shoot me an email um and um
you know with this and then just try it
if it works
so because i i don't think i i've come
across the type of data that you that
you're talking about so
that's as far as i can tell sorry
thank you we have a couple of questions
in the path of
chat um
oh i'm sorry the thing is just
refreshing on me can the points be
geopositions
yes and they are that's that's what i
was
showing at the beginning um the canada
data the city's rgo positions
and yes the methods uh compensate for
the non-cartesian coordinates um
in some in some cases we we look at the
geo distance
and um you know and we look at uh
you know will lose the geo distance the
problem is that the computation's more
much slower so
um in uh what we are doing um in many of
these computations here in the
um in the densities or in the
homogeneity measures
is that we project um and then do the
computations and then go back to the
geospace
okay the good thing is that you can see
now the output of the special pinpoint
data
that will tell you that it's a
geographical data we have uh 103 beans
and it tells you that the type of beans
was given as a as a list
and so okay i'm i'm still looking if
there are any more questions
and um
uh the notebook yes i i think i will um
i will have to make a little changes to
the notebook before i upload it and make
it available
um also you know this is all very
experimental
um functionality and so just want to
make sure that there is a
you know a beta coming that uh this
functionality works
you know and that we have things kind of
fun finalized so yes
and um okay
so i guess that that's all for the
questions i see and since we're out of
time i'm i'm gonna just say thank you
um and as i said if some questions pop
up later
you know feel free to contact me and
stop by eduardo stock which starts right
now
so thank you thank you all for coming
you